Speaker 1: David, even though Rhonda
Santurce has made Florida into covid hell,
could it somehow help him politically,
including maybe when he runs or if he
runs in twenty four? Yeah, I talked about this a
little bit on Monday. If you just think logically,
you would look at what's happening in Florida,
record Casey's record hospitalization,
relatively low vaccination rate, and Rhonda
Santurce going around saying we're banning mask
mandates. We're not going to make kids in school
wear masks, open everything, no limits on it. OK,
you would see that and you would say this
is going to backfire. This is going to be
terrible for Rhonda Santurce. I don't really know
about that, because if thinking ahead, if Rhonda
Santurce chooses to challenge Trump in twenty four
or Trump doesn't even run and Rhonda Sanders does,
you already know or can predict the way that
Rhonda Sanders's handling of covid is going to
be done in terms of a revisionist history.
Rhonda Santurce, Rhonda Santurce will say,
I was the freedom person. We dealt with covid,
but we did it with freedom and we allowed people
to decide for themselves what they want. No
nanny state and Republicans around him will
probably cheer it on and say that's exactly
what he did. So while you and I I mean,
it's sort of like the Trump covid reaction. Now
you listen to Trump's former press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany, and other people that work
for Trump. They talk about Trump's handling of
covid as if it was great. It was one of the
worst in the world. And they've rewritten
history to say it was great. It was absolutely
fantastic. So while it should hurt Ronda Santos,
how disastrously he has made Florida into
covid Hell Central over the last month or two,
it will almost certainly be reframed so that
the right will only talk about the good things.
We supported business and business owners by
opening businesses and letting business owners
and people decide what they feel safe
doing. That's the way it should be.
We don't want the government in your
business. I know that you're saying, David,
that you sound insane when you say that. Yeah, I'm
telling you what they will say and it is insane,
but if we've learned anything over the last few
years, it's that these people will fall for insane
narratives. These people will fall for absolutely
false stories about what's going on in the world.
So I wouldn't say Ron DeSantis destroying Florida
is going to be helpful to him. But I do think
that his destroying Florida can be rewritten
into a story about freedom and being about
letting business owners run businesses that
might end it. Maybe it might end up making it
sort of like a break, even for Rhonda Santos, if
he were to run in 2024 or even in terms of just
reelection for the Florida governorship. If you
disagree with me, definitely. Let me let me know,